[Musica]
e l'alba di un giorno di primavera un
contadino si sveglia fuori si sente
ronzio di un robot che sta posizionando
accuratamente semi e piantine sui solchi
preparati da un altro robot un trattore
energia solare che ha lavorato durante
la notte
conosciamo questo contadino si chiamava
anni con una laurea in fisica come me
straordinaria coincidenza ha una
specializzazione in fisica e tecnologia
dei plasmi life ai contadini io faccio
il ricercatore anno fa una grande
differenza perché quando lui va al
lavoro non va nei campi
entra in un laboratorio accende delle
apparecchiature da queste
apparecchiature si sprigiona una luce di
vari colori azzurro verde espone piante
e semi a questa luce oppure espone
dell'acqua che poi userà per irrigare
altre piante ed altri semi siamo tutti
quello di sapere che sta facendo questo
contadina ma prima concentriamoci su
questa luce diretto e un plasma group
per sapere cos'è un plasma per
conoscerlo meglio facciamo insieme un
breve viaggio nel tempo
intanto posizioniamo la scenario
descritto questa speriamo accada fra
dieci anni 2030 per sapere cos'è un
plasma facciamo un breve viaggio nel
tempo qualche anno prima
pochi anni solo 13 miliardi e mezzo di
anni
l'universo è ancora giovane è nato da
poco è perfetto da gravità
l'idrogeno si sta concentrando in grandi
ammassi a questo punto la pressione
entrano di questi ammassi è tale per cui
le temperature servizi superano i dieci
milioni di gradi a quel punto si innesca
la fusione nucleare
questo processo che libera enorme
quantità di energia che accende le
stelle e le mantiene
esattamente come il nostro sola ora
poniamoci una domanda ma la materia in
una stella con la temperatura in che
stato e non può essere solido non può
essere un liquido non può essere nemmeno
un gas perché quelle temperature gli
atomi si sono già a scissi i nuclei
positivi ed elettroni negativi
si parla di plasma esattamente il quarto
stato la materia
ora per famiglia risarcì ancora un po di
più con le proprietà
facciamo un esercizio tutti assieme
allora tutti voi quando siete entrati
avete sicuramente ricevuto una moneta
d'oro come ricordo per questo evento
ebbene questa mostra moneta d'oro
presidente così gelosamente nelle vostre
tasche mio via dovete lanciarla e
tentare di recuperarla
la situazione può sembrare un po confusa
ma in realtà ci sono delle regole molto
molto precisa dove ci sono le monete ci
sono le persone noi sono monete non sono
persone alcune monete escono alcune
persone seguiranno bene abbiamo imparato
due proprietà fondamentali del plasma la
prima la cosiddetta quasi neutralità
il plasma tende davvero stesso numeri
cariche positive e negative in tutte le
sue parti
la seconda proprietà molto importante il
quesito trasportano bipolare sono in
qualche modo riusciamo a governare le
particelle più leggere di elettroni ecco
che anche quelle più pesanti per
seguiranno come le monete e le persone
ovvero quando noi realizziamo un plasma
un laboratorio o qualche applicazione
con una scarica elettrica e quindi con
un campo elettrico possiamo innesca de
plasma ma anche poi soprattutto dargli
una forma adesso vediamo facciamo un
altro passettino avanti ma in questa
questo plasmi sono tutti così caldi come
una stella come fa il nostro contadino
esporre in modo sicuro semi e piante
senza di questi vengono distrutti altra
in realtà i plasmi sono una famiglia
molto molto numerosa pensate che più del
99 per cento della materia osservare
l'universo è fatta di plasma e
all'interno di questi plasmi c'è una
classe dei plasmi particolarmente
interessanti che sono detti tasm i
freddi
l'esempio più spettacolare che abbiamo
noi in natura sulla terra di tasm a
freddo e l'aurora boreale questo
spettacolo meraviglioso che illumina i
cieli dei cieli delle regioni polari
questi colori stupefacenti verde azzurro
rosso che ci sono informazioni
preziosissime perché ci dicono quali
sono le molecole gli atomi che dice
citando si emettono quella della luce
sono a tema molecole stati eccitati dal
plasma prodotta a sua volta da
radiazione solare
ecco che allora cominciamo a capire un
po meglio come può essere un plasma
freddo per darvi un'idea torniamo al
nostro esercizio avete recuperato la
vostra moneta e soddisfatti tenendolo in
mano cercate di tornare alla vostra
posta nel fare questo verrete urtati da
tre persone che stava cercando
affannosamente loro moneta o scivolerete
su altre monete
insomma rischiando di perderla vostra
preziosa moneta quindi sarete quantomeno
un po irritati bene un plasma freddo è
praticamente fatto di una maggioranza di
persone che stanno tornando al loro
posto con la loro moneta e sono molto
molto irritate quello che noi chiamiamo
e citazioni di armi di molecole ora per
rivelare usare un linguaggio
scientificamente più appropriato quello
che sta accadendo e che questi elettroni
stanno viaggiando a queste enormi e da
fare questo compie un milione di urti
con molecole più pesanti come per
esempio una mole così jack queste 30.000
volte in pesanti l'elettrone durante
questi oltre possono capitare vari
processi letto una porta via un altro
elettrone oppure spezza la molecola
oppure la metà in vibrazione la metti
uno stato eccitato quello che citavo
prima e questo è praticamente
interessante perché quando le molecole
sono così e citate sono particolarmente
propense a ricombinarsi e combinarsi
nuove molecole per esempio una molecola
d'acqua
a quel punto può assumere un altro
idrogeno oppure un altro ossigeno può
spezzarsi è creata un gruppo ossigeno e
idrogeno che particolarmente reattivo un
cosiddetto radicale ora la particolarità
di questi plasmi flat nel tanto nel
fatto di creare queste molecole alcuni
dei quali possono essere esotiche non
altrimenti ottenibili
ma quanto il fatto che questa molecola
mentre seccamente tempi di vita diversi
alcune durano giorni altre due frazioni
di secondo in un tasm alfredo le
possiamo mettere tutte assieme
simultaneamente e qui viene l'aspetto
interessante quello che il nostro
contadino sta facendo in questa
ipotetica fattoria solare il 2030
sono le tecnologie che stiamo
sviluppando ai nostri laboratori in
questi giorni è quello che noi vediamo è
straordinario quando non esponiamo i
semi per esempio al plasma o all'acqua
attivata dal plasma osserviamo
germinazioni più rapide osserviamo che
le piante sono più robuste radici
profonde foglie più grandi piante che
rischiano media gli stress climatici
come la siccità la solidità delle acque
l'aumento delle temperature raccolti più
abbondanti prodotti più ricchi entry
enti una plasma una pianta attaccato da
un patogeno esposta un plasma o
all'acqua trattata al plasma può curare
la malattia della pianta senza usare
fitofarmaci addirittura possiamo usando
queste tecniche allenare preparare le
piante prima dell'attacco dei patogeni
in qualche modo vaccinarli ebbene questi
effetti così straordinarie che stiamo
studiando in questo momento ci sono già
manifestati realtà tempo mi padre della
scienza molto recente questa è la plasma
di calcio mai sono già manifestati anni
prima in un altro settore
la medicina dove l'applicazione elitaria
del plasma è stata la sterilizzazione
potete immaginare che un plasma di per
sé può essere un ambiente estremamente
ostile particelle cariche radicali campi
elettrici un radiazione x batteri e
virus un ambiente micidiale infatti
viene usata principalmente per
sterilizzare strumenti o materiali
biologici ma poi si è scoperto che
riducendo le dosi diminuendo i tempi di
trattamento sono altri fenomeni
interessanti popolazioni più rapida non
l'hai artificiale semplicemente veniva
incrementato accelerato il processo
naturale di coagulazione a tal punto che
si poteva usare queste tecniche per
curare piaghe altrimenti incurabili
ma un altro effetto importante che sta
studiando e la morte delle cellule
tumorali
perché in qualche modo il plasma stimola
l'assorbimento di radicali che lui
stesso produce e le cellule possano
andare spontaneamente in apoptosi c'è in
morte cellulare
quello che vi sto presentando quindi
sono applicazioni in biologia ma non è
l'unico settore in cui stiamo applicando
questi plasmi freddi sono altre
applicazioni che possono sembrare che
sono altrettanto interessanti e sono le
applicazioni che vengono fatte nel
settore dell'ambiente per esempio usando
questi plasmi che sono estremamente
reattivi si può per esempio sintetizzare
fertilizzanti ora latitante sono a base
di azoto è la più grande riserva di
azoto che noi abbiamo e la nostra
atmosfera
allora si può usando questi plasmi
assorbire l'azoto l'atmosfera
sintetizzarlo in fertilizzanti che
verrebbero dati nella quantità giusta
localmente e nel momento giusto in cui
serve la pianta evitando quindi quella
dispersione sostanze azotate di
fertilizzanti che in questo momento sta
inquinando alle acque del nostro pianeta
un'altra applicazione interessante poi
se proprio per l'inquinamento perché i
plasmi sono estremamente di molecole
prodotte dei plavi estremamente reattive
ecco che allora possono aggredire tutti
composti che stanno all'interno quelli
indesiderati gli inquinanti che stanno
dentro all'aria all'acqua sono talmente
reattive che possono arrivare a
distruggere anche le quantità più
infinitesime quelle responsabili degli
odori
l'ultima applicazione volevo segnalarvi
e la dissociazione della co2 l'anidride
carbonica questa molecola che sta
rischiando di alterare l'equilibrio
climatico del nostro pianeta
ebbene anche nella co2 si può scomporre
al cretino stesso modo riaggregare in
altri composti utili come presente
fertilizzanti oppure con combustibili
in ogni caso impedire che la co2 venga
immessa in atmosfera e in questo modo
immagazzinarla in sostanza e ultima
comunque in una forma che sia comunque
sostanzialmente immagazzinate quindi
sequestrare in modo stabile sicuro e co2
ora potete immaginare che quello che vi
ho descritto racconta una scienza che
inter sicamente complessa inter
sicamente multidisciplinare noi
lavoriamo spalla a spalla con piolo g
chimici ingegneri perché tutti assieme
solo così possiamo affrontare la
complessità di questo tipo di scienze
della tecnologia che legate a questa
scienza però un'idea della complessità
immaginate quel processo che ho appena
descritto la dissociazione della co2
siamo una cosa semplice bacio è una
molecola con un carbonio e 2 ossigeno
ebbene appena viene in contatto con un
plasma prodotto in aria immediatamente
immediatamente il sigillo decine di
specie chimiche e queste decine specie
chimiche interagiscono con centinaia di
reazioni fra di loro e ogni reazione è
estremamente sensibile alla temperatura
la composizione del gas agli altri
specie che già esistono quindi in tutto
questo vediamo che affrontiamo tematiche
tematiche complesse infatti sono
ricerche di frontiera in cui
comunichiamo con altri settori che
affrontano i problemi dei sistemi
complessi come gli ecosistemi sistemi
biologici sistemi economici e sociali e
da loro mutuiamo e
andiamo tecniche algoritmi innovativi
che ci permettono di studiare sistemi
complessi ma anche di controllarle per
questo il nostro obiettivo principale
ora stiamo arrivando alla conclusione e
nella conclusione
io ritornerei a quella data 2030 che ho
citato all'inizio in cui ho collocato
questa fattoria solare diciamolo con
questa ipotetico scenario del futuro ben
230 non è una scelta casuale è una
scelta è una data ben precisa che è
citata dalla reazione mondiale
dell'agricoltura dell'alimentazione la
favo perché per 2030 avremo una
popolazione mondiale che sarà
ulteriormente aumentata per soddisfare
le necessità alimentari di queste
popolazioni avrò bisogno di più suolo
più acqua più fertilizzanti quindi
immaginate l'impatto ambientale il tutto
questo potrà avere per darne idea
dell'impatto
pensate solo alla filiera alimentare dal
momento in cui si crea le fertilizzante
si coltiva sia raccoglie si trasforma si
conserva fino alle nostre tavole
tutto questo assorbe il 30 per cento dei
consumi mondiali dell'energia e sono
fonti fossili sono fonti che hanno
problemi di inquinamento problemi di
effetto serra che sono estremamente
importanti
dobbiamo quindi dotarci in questo in
questi anni di tecnologie che ci
permettono uno sviluppo sostenibile
l'agricoltura sostenibile
la tecnologia che vi ho presentato e una
potenziale di queste e sembra
estremamente interessante perché diciamo
sfrutta l'aria l'acqua l'energia solare
non emette sostanze chimiche permanenti
nell'ambiente
ma c'è un altro aspetto che è molto
importante perché quando lo si fa figli
alimentare assorbe il 30 per cento
dell'energia
purtroppo un altro aspetto importante
che di quel cibo prodotto sprechiamo
fino al 30 per cento
ecco che allora le tecnologie ci possono
aiutare
sono strumenti utili sì ma non sono
sufficienti dobbiamo anche associare a
questo comportamenti responsabili
dobbiamo usare in modo responsabile e
attento tutte le risorse compresa l'aria
e l'acqua
dobbiamo essere attenti a non sprecare
prima di tutto il cibo
ecco che allora in questo modo se noi
riusciamo a coniugare comportamenti
virtuosi una scienza
attenta e curiosa della natura è una
tecnologia responsabile verso l'ambiente
ecco che in questo modo possiamo
presentare il nostro pianeta
magari anche correggere tutti i guasti
che abbiamo prodotto fino ad ora
e questo lo dobbiamo fare per i nostri
figli e per le future generazioni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]